I'm lla I'm John I'm
Cassandra and today we're going to be
judging whether adults are cool or not I
was initially excited to do this because
I'm raising a middle schooler and so for
me I'm going to test some material out I
want to see uh if maybe some of the
stuff's going to work on my daughters do
you have kids yeah you're like you're
like the cool dad that's what you are
what are you saying that you're not a
cool dad I couldn't tell you if I'm a
cool dad or not cuz if you ask my
daughter she'd be like
no all right I've got to I'll do some
dad jokes this is the worst one all
right knock knock who's Britney Spears
Britney Spears who knock knock who's
there oops I Did It
Again did that did that work I love you
you are amazing thank you um your
personality is amazing you're funny
thank you I now you're making me my
middle school boys could
never you are an amazing person yeah
You' be like the best dad like thank
you I sneezed you're saying he's not
cool how dare you honestly I don't know
you're like a really nice person but I
feel like you kind of like embarrassed I
could do some more work right yeah
little more I think it went great I mean
the these kids are fun they really
wanted to to kind of intimidate
everybody and I think they recognized
that they were wielding a lot of power
they you know what they all said I was
nice and and for me that was that was
pretty good I've always personally felt
like I'm cool I just think that everyone
around me has a different perspective hi
my name is Joanne hi Jo what is your
favorite Starbucks drink if you go to
Starbucks oo I like the uh passion Tango
lemonade
okay okay what are your hobbies I like
to dance can you show us your best dance
moves oh my
God thank no music oh God no music hey
you no music I don't know no
music
[Applause]
gosh thank you guys it's okay you're
really pretty thank you uh I didn't get
all cools but that's okay I'm so cool in
my own heart I'm scared but I feel like
it could be humbling you know and maybe
it's time to hear some hard truths your
name my name's Lizzy I like to read
books I'm sorry read reading books is
just kind of boring you don't like doing
anything else I like skiing like Winter
Ski and water skiing okay so then like
why read books yeah I I agree I can do
better so so Friday night you know you
don't want to be a party pooper so
you're like you know what let me get on
the Dance Floor what are you going to
start doing just like a little bit of
this okay hurt my knees okay at least
you did
it never do that again in your whole
entire life no no never not
once sorry I dropped it I came out of
there alive with a cool rating and boy
did they get me I I probably can't ever
handle something like that again I think
they might think I'm trying too hard
like I really thought about this outfit
I'm not going to tell them that I'm only
telling you guys
that what's your name my name is B Be EA
where did you get the jacket from um so
I made this jacket oh my gosh so like
you collected all the patches and stuff
yeah well kind of I bought a vintage lot
of patches on eBay and then some of them
were my dad like my dad volunteered at
this um fire station in college I am in
love with your jacket I think it's so
cool how you like made it yourself
jacket is fire yeah I like I like your
personality and you're also very pretty
oh thank you a
[Music]
that's so cool thank you guys oh my God
cools across the board which I was kind
of surprised by but they really weren't
as ruthless as I thought they were going
to be my name is Alexa I am excited I'm
a little bit worried I just can't
imagine a situation where they're like I
really approve how many followers do you
have on Instagram I don't have an
Instagram do you have a do you have any
social
medias I don't have any social media
okay
okay your shoes are kind of beat
um I don't like beat
shoes I don't mind your outfit so yeah I
don't I don't like mind outfit like this
was a little beat up but like a
little I sneezed I'm sorry I sneezed oh
my
God I was only thinking about appearance
I am cool with myself you know I'm
really not a kids person Middle School
boys my worst nightmare I think I'll get
three cools but realistically hi nice oh
yeah your hair is cute thanks wow okay I
like the nose nose ring you lived in
Rhode Island no I just have this
shirt so um what are some of your
hobbies um I like to eat food I like to
travel I like to watch
TV okay um I think that's all I do damn
that's kind of
sad Prime Netflix Hulu peacock or
Paramount ooh I might go Prime no Hulu
Hulu Hulu what do you like to do like
during your free time um like go home
and lay in my bed and watch TV nothing
else that's so sad no Netflix and chill
like there's no one to chill with I
don't
know me personally are you crying no
it's
mine oh no I'm good I'm good woo hit on
my childhood trauma for Mom you know she
just wants me to oh my God be dating you
know I forgot I was
[Applause]
to I got three
Knuckles one
second
a lot of judgments lot of immediate
judgments I don't think they like me and
I don't think I like them I'm a little
nervous middle schoolers are kind of
terrifying nice to meet you hi hi what's
your name my name is Skyler you look
like you're into zodiac signs I am do
you like crystals I'm not a crystal
person what do you like to do for fun I
usually like
reading you have great energy and I just
think you're like such a nice person and
very posi um I I I think you're a very
nice person very cool but um
[Music]
BS a I sneezed I'm sorry
oh you know what two out of three I'll
take it I got two out of three the only
reason I didn't get the third cool was
because I liked books and you know kids
they've got other things to worry about
like that's fine this was very like
validating and I can go and tell my
friends to Middle School think I'm cool
thanks for watching cool or not
cool my name is Hassan I'm a bounce in
New York City tonight we going to find
out who's under 21 in this line I've
worked at different clubs I've worked
with specific artists like hardi B when
she came back to lust but really what I
did was make sure the youngans a get in
the club hey how you feeling awesome
sorry I had you standing online so long
we got a lot of lot of activities going
on I quick question for you um what year
you graduate high school 2015 2015 sure
yes I remember you in college I I went
to college yeah you went to college
yeah do me favorite back of line for me
okay let get back to you simple tells
when somebody gets online I shouldn't be
there they like to avoid eye contact
most people avoid all natural behaviors
because in the back of their mind
they're like I don't want to get caught
or I've already been caught next up how
you feeling I'm I'm okay you ready to go
in sure ready to get a drink yeah yeah
are you old enough to drink yeah how old
are you I'm 25 you're 25 what year you
born uh 98 98 mhm I didn't know that was
a year y it's a year what other spots
should be going to um like other bars in
the area you've been the sunshines over
there
uh no I haven't no oh uh sunshines don't
exist can you go to the back of line for
me how you doing this evening hi I'm
good you look like you here to trick
somebody H what's your favorite drink I
love Ving cranber that's usually my
go-to Ving cranber when the first time
you had a drink uh recently actually you
didn't have a drink until you turned
21 I wasn't a huge Drinker no I respect
it you want to do the right thing yeah
yeah that's what most people do the
right thing how you doing this evening
doing good what you doing 1989 1989 oh
you old you like me We up there saying I
don't see no crows feet but you look
like you use a moisturizer all right
what you us on your face take care of
myself lotion lotion that's it
yeah something ain't right go to the
back of line for me let me get back to
you how you doing this evening hi who
your friends they got a table yeah they
do they got table how old are you 25 did
you go to college I did you did and what
year you graduated 2019
straight out yeah took that career
serious out for sure what you do for
work I'm a media strategist media
strategist
yeah that sound like I might need to
work with you yeah you might okay well
we trying to figure out what's going on
on line do me a fav go to the back of
the line I'm going to get back to you
step on up my friend how old are you I
am 22 since when since 1999 when did you
graduate high school when yeah uh 2019
2019 yeah what was your favorite show as
a
kid I like that's Raven where you like
to visit um usually any cleer plac like
where I know a few uh the que oh yeah
what well that Clos um I was going to
say I thought that closed now
uh go to back in the line I'm going get
back to you hi how you doing I'm good
what year were you born 97 97 quick fire
what year you graduate high school 2015
2015 not 2013 no no not 2017 no that
wouldn't be the right year ask no no I
understand did you go to college yes
what college you go to NYU you went the
NYU hard worker yo what's your favorite
cartoon as a kid I wasn't allowed to
watch cartoon were you a Mormon no my
parents just wouldn't I don't know I was
never allowed to watch SpongeBob The
Simpsons anything okay he we going to
find out if you impost go to the back of
the line for me let me get back with you
in a minute now that I've talked to
everybody in line I'mma figure out who's
going to get in the club who's not get
in the club I'm sorry I can't let you
win shiee you can't come in this club
not tonight okay maybe in a year or two
next
up I might be swapping you on her route
but I need you to go over there for now
champ what's up hi how you feeling I'm
good you better not be the impostor no
I'm not are you sure I mean that's up to
you to decide I'm going to let you go up
in there go get a drink don't start no
problems of course thank
you Mr 30s Mr 30s all I'm not
going to waste your time sir go up in
there enjoy your night here let me get
you up in there I'mma let you go in
tonight thank you don't fo me
wrong step one up my friend how are you
I'm good how are you welcome back to the
line thank you how old are you I am
22 good choice go on and enjoy your
drink all right thank you don't start no
problems thank you next up hey what's up
how you feeling better than ever I'm
going to let you go have a drink tonight
I would really love that I really hope
you're not the impostor I hope for you
that's the truth I hope so
too all right so I pick them two just
basically because of the stuttering uh
it seemed too too too too too off tilt
I'm going to take the chance and let you
win because you seem to have the eyes
that show you might be a little bit
closer to the truth I'm going to let you
enjoy your drink tonight thank and I'm
pretty sure this is my impostor I'm
sorry you can't come in not tonight
young lady hopefully when you're of
age welcome back thank you I'm 25
25 thank you enjoy your
drinks you again yes how old are you I'm
28 flabbergast at 28
yeah
hello again hi how old are you I'm 22 22
okay so you should be here
enjoy it's the 30s you better not tell
me you 17 I'm going be very upset how
old are you my friend 32 32 let's go you
should be here having drinks with me in
fact we shouldn't be here we too old for
this what we doing hello guys hi how old
are you I'm 25
we get to the truth all right of these
two what do you
think my friend right here on the left
how old are you I'm 20 20 can't come in
tonight I'd like to get my drink now
enjoy your
drink you won yeah you won the game of
the night cuz you got in some my club
under age and all do you do this often
um I do not very good very good do me a
favor wait till 21 and pop back out okay
I'll wait my guy I don't think I'm going
to be able to guess the Virgin from a
lineup here's the thing just because
you're a virgin doesn't mean you're a
bad kisser and just because you're a bad
kisser doesn't mean you're a virgin I'm
just trying to be ready for everything
if people are going to go in with tongue
are people expecting just like a peck on
the
cheek
kinky I think I'm fighting my nerves my
confidence is trying to
override will think urg bed kissing nope
NOP nope no no no I've never gotten a
complaint you know but hey I'm I'm ready
let's let's do it you know I don't don't
worry you're a good kisser just any
insecurities that was I enjoyed I'm
pretty confident that they're not the
Virgin I was just like oh my
God I was trying to ease her into what
we was about to do you know relax the
situation you know you were the one who
was breathing I told I told you to
breathe too you know I was fine see I
was nervous but it was good thank you
thank you thank you thank you I just
find this as like a hilarious first
introduction to people like just telling
them how like good of a kisser they
are you know I don't think I've ever
kissed anybody who I don't know so this
is like totally new and it's like kind
of weird and nice there's like a really
soft like sensual like I want to fall in
love with you and probably will and then
there's like I'm coming after you we're
and we're going to like like like just
where I'm at in that moment and like my
intention oh my God you
just that there just like a horor move
you're
like why is that nervous you're you're
the one who like give so much nervous f
I I know in the beginning I said like I
don't want to like off anyone assuming
that they're the Virgin but like like
I'm sorry you think it's me I have a I
have a sense like it wasn't number one I
have a feeling it might be
you yeah I mean I will say I don't feel
awkward you sure yeah gosh um I think
I'm a pretty good kisser I've been
complimented before I'd like to believe
them I mean I think it's interesting cuz
the best kisses to me have been like
with the people I already have kind of
an emotional connection with and like
completely stripped of that I don't know
I think it I have no
idea my hands are a little cold sorry
it's
okay nose is what's
called there's like some confidence that
was in it I can't tell like if that's
supposed to like throw me off but like I
like it like personally I don't know if
it says very much about me but I always
love a compliment so sure it says
everything I honestly don't know it's
it's it's weird I also don't feel like
kissing really brings out that much of a
person I think it's what experience
you're in in the moment and what your
mood is and what their mood is and how
well you know each other and everything
like that but it's been a while it's
been and Co it's it's weird
hi touch your face
yeah I mean like I still think like
number two is kind of up there one and
three were just so confident and just
like show that level of confident that
like you bring to like the bedroom if
you're trying to hook up with someone
this is number four right number four
and number two are probably like the
comp the contenders at this point this
feels like we're in the lineup of an
improv show I don't know if anyone feels
that way like that's how it feels for me
so it's like I don't know if that's good
for kissing but you know we'll find out
I guess we're not we don't know what's
going to happen so hi hi uh is that
right if I put my hand on your shoulder
sure
okay
yeah number two was really awkward like
in comparison it just sticks out so much
in comparison to like the rest of them
some people could be sweet and number
five proved it or just like you be sweet
and go with it it's going to be
hilarious if it turns out number two is
not the Virgin like surprisingly now I
think about it I'm just like leaning
towards just a sweetness level of like
kisses I'll give number two another
chance all right number two do you feel
okay with that
sure do you want my hand again
yeah
same the thing is
like it like the thought just occurred
to my head it's so middle schoolly to
like just hold your hands like that in
my kiss like the kiss isn't bad but just
the Ambiance is just like
strange oh my
God I don't think number two necessarily
gives like the Virgin Vibes the handing
does but like based on the kiss I think
the Virgin
is number
four
yeah I want to say it's because of like
the certain mood that was that it was
like sweetest it was sweetest it was
just so
sweet like At first I was thinking that
like four and five were definitely the
sweetest especially like number two like
just taking account of like the kiss not
like necessarily like the free thing the
Ambiance the idea of like what you
perceive a kiss as you know I don't
think that has to do with appearances
you can tell a lot from the kiss I feel
like you know because
your personality is going to shine
somewhere your nerves or something
whatever you're feeling in that moment
is going to come out it it's really
funny that you said like bedroom energy
cuz I was like that is exactly the
opposite of the intention I had I wasn't
confident until number two went and then
I was confident because of everything
she had to say should have really gone
for it now but as she was saying that
bedroom energy I word I have experience
or something I would be more comfortable
kind of if anything just mimicking
versus now I'm just flying blond I'm
like guessing this works it was it was
odd but it was fun it was it was a fun
experience meatball how do you feel
about Britney Spears hi my name is
Alicia and today I'm going to be picking
a date based on their dog I have a cat
she is the love of my life she is my DOA
cat DOA is the sweetest girl she's very
sassy I love dogs I am not responsible
enough to have one myself which is why I
have a cat but I love dogs I am a dog
person and I am so excited what I'm
looking for in a match is somebody who
is vaccinated and supports the free
Britney movement I'm not sure if I'm
going to end up going on a date with a
guy if I'm going to end up going on a
date with a woman but I'm open and I'm
excited either
way hey how's it going my name's Gavin
uh this is my Behemoth of a dog Hefty I
love Hefty because he has got a lot of
personality I think the number one
priority for me is somebody who can love
and accept this giant the way that I do
I think she's going to love him but I
think it'll be like oh my God he's so
chunky Bulldog oh I think he's a shoe in
to be picked it doesn't get much cuter
than this little meatball hi I'm Janine
and this is my dog and wingwoman
meatball honestly meatball is a hit
people want to talk to her and then I'm
like you know that's meatball and um I'm
Janine me and meatball both have all of
our shots so uh we're ready to get out
there meet some people get some smooches
go in be very nice thank you tell her
I'm nice
you got this champ no pressure but it's
do or die this is my love life hi my
name's Hannah and I'm here with my dog
Penny she's kind of a reflection of me
I'm very independent and she also is
very independent she's like my my child
so it's really important to me that
whoever I date loves her as much as I
love her she is my best friend we try
and do everything together she's kept me
sane throughout the pandemic I don't
know what I'd do without her Penny pleas
please don't embarrass me you want to
get me a date yeah I am ready to meet
some dogs let's go
hi come here buddy hi dude you are
chunky you are chunkie what did I say
this is a solid dog you guys like you
protect me huh hi oh I got the good spot
right there if he sits on people that's
how you know that like he likes him hi
my name is Hefty
I'm a 5-year-old English Bulldog I love
going on picnics with my parent anything
outside that involves food I'm all in
for I could have guessed that you like
food dude you're chewing on your leash
like it's a treat I knew it I knew he
chewed on his leash okay so I love that
his name is Hefty because that just
makes so much sense um it tells me that
the owner definitely has a sense of
humor I love Bulldogs I just love like I
hope that the owner can't hear me saying
this but I love ugly dogs you're not
ugly I think Hefty is owned by a hipster
and that's cool I like hipsters I wore
the wrong shirt today didn't I bye Hefty
nice to meet you I hope your owner is as
cute as
you hi baby this is a cute little
sausage you're so adorable the coat is
very soft a lot of people talk about the
soft coat to hit let's learn a little
more about you hi I'm
meatball that's the cutest name so far
cutest name I come on strong cuz I'm
excited to see you but give me a few
minutes I'll be asleep on your leg
anyway want a kiss ooh meatballs
flirting with me what kind of Vibes am I
getting from meatball I definitely think
that meatball is probably owned by a
comedian because the name is hilarious
nailed it I love it when people name
their animals after food when I first
got meatball she didn't have a name for
like 3 weeks and I would just call call
her random things and I literally was
making a meatball pizza and then I
called her meatball and my roommates at
the time ran out and were like her
name's meatball and then it it worked
it's great this seems like the kind of
dog who definitely is going to give you
like high energy when you need it but
also definitely down to like snuggle and
take a nap too which I like yes finally
meatball is being understood I
definitely think I would vibe with
meatballs owner this is definitely the
kind of dog that I would adopt you get
all the perks of having a dog but kind
of like the energy of a cat she's for
sure half cat mea do you support the
free Britney movement mea wants to free
Britney she's very passionate about it
bye meepo nice to meet you I hear a
pitter patter of tiny feet no freaking
way hi
sweetie oh my gosh hi my name is Penny
I'm a 2-year-old Cavalier King Charles
Spaniel that's a really long breed
everyone says I act like a puppy like my
owner I'm up for anything whether it's
an all day hike or an afternoon lounging
on the couch I love naps me too I have
lots of love to give as you can probably
tell I can tell Penny Penny Penny she's
not focusing she doesn't pay much
attention Okay can you sit come on Penny
Focus oh oh you got an itch I don't know
that might have been a fluke let's see
she's always scratching her ears
sit good girl you guys she's really
itchy should I be concerned about that I
swear she doesn't have flee I feel like
penny owner is a girl I don't know why
but I just have a feeling I am is your
owner as cute as you are she's probably
cutter than me you can tell that she's
well taken care of well groomed and
these are all really good signs you guys
good job Penny hie Penny I'll miss you
all right so I met three really cute
dogs today first we had Hefty the
bulldog who was indeed very Hefty super
cute very loving then we had meatball
who was just a total ham I love meatball
next we had Penny who was just the
prettiest girl I've ever seen she was
adorable okay this is so hard you guys I
loved Hefty he was so cute but I just
feel like he was a little too um how do
you say it rambunctious is that a word I
love the way he waddled around on his
back but you know what he kind of left
me smelling a little like dogs I own a
dog dogs smell like dogs I can't really
do anything about it I could bathe him
but they they'll smell like wet dog and
I think wet dog smells worse so that
leaves us with Penny and meatball both
super sweet dogs I can tell that they
have great owners but at the end of the
day I think that Penny was just a little
bit mellow for me oh a misdirect if
Penny wasn't number one then it wasn't
meant to be I like to have fun and
that's why I'm going to pick meatball
because meatball was just a joy to play
with a joy to see and I'm really excited
to see who owns meatball you made the
right choice I'll say it hi Hi how are
you I'm good how are you Alicia nice to
meet you nice to meet you too thanks for
picking meatball she she had a lot of
good things to say about you oh did she
yeah she's adorable she definitely had a
good time she's a big flirt so she is
yeah I keep trying to tell her calm down
go easy but what can I do you know so
what do you think do you want to go on a
date yeah I'd love to mea's crying so
she would also love to all right we're
on our way to get some juice we got our
buddy with us hi she knows how to work
the camera all right here we are we're
on our date uh meatball is Big chilling
and one other person complimented
meatball so that is true somebody was
trying to swoop in on my girl it's been
a fun time you guys a good time on our
day um definitely feeling like I picked
the right choice meatball is a winner
meatball is a good one cheers to me Paul
cheers to meall to
meatball
[Music]
n